KUAN YONG: All right.
Welcome everybody to our talk
on YouTube API Uploads.
My name is Kuan.
I'm the Product Manager for the
YouTube Developer Platform.
And, together with the Jeff on
the Developer Relationship Team
and Gareth on our Engineering
Team, we're going to spend the
next 40, 45 minutes or so,
going over all of the different
ways that you can use our API
to upload videos to YouTube.
So, before we move on any
further, this is the wave link.
And, you know, if you want to
open up that in your browser,
take notes, post questions, and
we'll get to as many of them as
possible at the end
of the session.
Alright, a quick show of hands.
How many of you
guys -- I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KUAN YONG:
-- or you can go to the
main I/O page for wave.
And, it's got links to all
the different waves that
are set up for the talks.
Alright cool.
So, a quick show of hands.
How many of you guys have ever
uploaded a video to YouTube?
Oh wow.
That's kind of more
than I expected.
And, how many of you guys
have done so using the API?
Very impressive.
Well, the goal is of your
kind of familiarity level
with the YouTube API.
We hope that this session will
be useful to you, because we
are going to go through a lot
of the common upload flows.
For example, uploading from a
website, a web app, uploading
from a client app.
We're also going to talk about
new resumable upload API, which
will let you upload, you know,
huge multi-gigabyte files
in a reliable way.
Potentially, over a flaky
internet connection, so mobile
connection would be a good
example, and we'll show
you how to do that.
We'll also talk about best
practices for uploading
metadata that goes with your
video at upload time, bearing
in mind in some situations, the
best practices is to not give
us any metadata at all.
And, we'll talk about different
ways in which you can do that.
We'll also cover writing
upload apps for both
Android and the iPhone.
And, we'll wrap up by doing a
little discussion on our
flagship Open Source video
moderation and hosting
platform, that we built
entirely on top of the YouTube
APIs, and it runs on
Google App Engine.
And, we call that
YouTube Direct.
So, you know, why are we having
this talk in the first place.
Basically, we want
your content.
So, if you're building any sort
of app, any sort of service
that deals with videos, we'll
like you think of YouTube as
kind of your general
purpose video hosting
platform in a cloud.
Our APIs have been around
for many years now.
They're stable.
And, we continue to
improve upon them.
You may have heard a stat that
some 24 hours of videos are
uploaded to YouTube every
minute, but API accounts
for over 3 of those hours.
So, that's a lot of video
conten that's flowing
through the APIs.
There's one thing that you're
going to hear over and over
again during this presentation,
is that you should always let
your users upload their videos
to their own YouTube account.
YouTube is really not set up
for the use case, where you
create this mega-account, and
have all you users dump content
into that one account.
If you do that, your app will
never be able to scale, that
there's a limit on how many
videos can go into any single
want one YouTube account.
And, also you might want to
have to think about the
different product and legal
issues that could come up,
because your kind of asserting
ownership over everything that
gets uploaded to your
YouTube account.
And, in many cases, that's not
really what you want to do.
So, always let users upload
videos to their account.
We support OWA.
You know, there's really no
excuse for you to not do so.
Some other reminders
for anybody who's
using on the APIs.
If you're going to be sending
us requests, it's just polite
to identify yourself
in every request.
Right now.
We require a developer key
only when you're going
a write operation.
But, as a best practice, we
recommend sending us a
developer key with
every request.
Videos uploaded to YouTube can
only be up to ten minutes long.
But, if you are developing a
service for one of our official
content partners, this
limit may not apply to you.
Always give us your videos in
the highest possible quality.
You know, the original
source format.
Right now on YouTube,
we're encoding all of
our videos up to 10 ADP.
But, in the future if should
we decide to offer a high
resolution format, we do
actually go back to our video
catalog and re-process
all those videos.
So, if you want to future proof
your videos on YouTube, you
know, if you wanted your videos
to look great on that Google TV
device we announced this
morning, you know, you want to
make sure that you're giving us
the highest quality
possible content.
Finally, just note that as with
all the API requests, upload
requests are rate limited.
And, this may come up if you're
trying to do a bulk migration
of a whole bunch of
videos into YouTube.
And, a simple strategy that we
recommend for doing so, is to,
you know, upload as
fast as you can.
And, if you get a quota error,
simply just back off, do
nothing for 10 minutes,
and then resume.
And, it's a real easy
way to kind of manage
your usage quotas.
Alright, so Jeff will now tell
us -- tell you guys more about
how to upload from a web app.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
Thanks very much Kuan.
So, the first form of YouTube
API App, we can talked about
is browser-based uploads.
And, browser-based uploads are
perfect for the scenario
in which you have a web
application, and you want to
allow users to upload videos to
YouTube from within the context
of that web application.
Browser-based uploads and all
the other stuff we're going to
talk about are documented fully
in the YouTube API section
of Code.Google.com.
So, all the new gritty
details are there.
But, I'm going to give you kind
of a high level of review,
of how that's done.
So, browser-based uploads
work in a two-step process.
The first step involves a post
to specific well defined URL.
That post will normally
include all the metadata
about the video.
You know, we'll talk a little
bit more about kind of
incomplete metadata or
no metadata scenario.
But, you know, any of those
cases you're gonna have
to do an initial post.
What you get back from that
post is a unique pretty much a
security token, and a URL that
you will end up using to do the
actual upload of
the video data.
And, so, you know, it
could be potentially a
very large video file.
It's worth noting in this
scenario, the user selects a
file locally from their hard
drive, and their upload
directly to YouTube servers.
So, you know, user might be
uploading 500 megabytes, but
you don't actually have to, you
know, store that 500 megabytes
somewhere locally temporarily
on your servers.
It's just going
directly to YouTube.
So, it scales pretty well.
And, that's the case.
And, the way the actual file
upload is done is really pretty
much a simple HTML form post.
You know, form contains an
action element, and that action
element -- sorry action
attribute, and that would
be the URL that you get
back from the first up.
That's a unique URL.
And, it will have file elements
in which a person would have
selected the local file.
And, it will have a token,
which is just another -- in
addition to the unique URL --
it's just another way that we
make sure that you're actually
uploading on behalf of the
user that you say you are.
So, I'm going to show
you an example of
that in a little bit.
I just want to mention and
reinforce something that you're
going to hear a lot, which is
there's really no excuse
in this case not to use
either AuthSub or OAuth.
AuthSub and OAuth are very
similar in their purpose.
And, basically what it'll let
you do is obtain credentials to
upload videos or to take any
action on behalf
of a given user.
And, it will allow you to do
that without actually having
to request the users log
in name or password.
You know, obviously, nobody out
here, and nobody watching this
would write malicious
applications.
And, you know, do anything
nasty with people's
usernames and passwords.
But, we really feel better if
the user name and passwords
get entered on webpages
that are hosted by Google.
And, what you'll actually do is
get back a token that you could
use pretty much indefinitely
to make requests on
that users behalf.
And, I'll walk you through that
process, right now actually.
So, I have a couple of
examples, one example that has
both the source code and a log
demo that I'm going to pull up.
In this particular case, it's
doing browser-based uploads
from the context of an
ActionScript 3 Flash
application, which is kind of
cool, and it actually makes use
of ActionScript 3' support for
AuthSub, which we just recent
-- about 6 months
ago announced.
So, it might be something that
you haven't seen before.
It's certainly something
that seems to be a
common enough scenario.
We worked with a lot of
advertisors, the who write
stuff in ActionScript, and
might want to solicit
uploads to YouTube.
And, this is kind of good
reference code for that.
But, it also is just a
good general purpose
explanation on how to do
browser-based uploads.
So, I'm going to
pull up that TEMPO.
Things are a little
small on the screen.
So pardon that.
But, cool things I wan to
show you at least are the
AuthSub user for that sign.
And, that gets initiated by
clicking on the login button.
I happend to already be signed
in to my YouTube/Google
accounts at this point.
Right over here.
But, if I weren't it would
ask me to initially enter
my username and password.
Because I'm already signed in,
it takes me directly to the
second step in the AuthSub
process, which is authorizing
access to the target
webpage for my accounts.
In this particular case, I
haven't registered ahead
of time hum for this
particular shockwave file.
And, that means you'll
see a little bit of a
scary warning message.
But, we'll talk a little bit
later, and I'll show you an
example little bit later about
registering and the type of
message you'll see
in that scenario.
In any case, I do trust this
application, so, I'm going
to click allow access.
And, a re-direction is
done back to the flash
content that we have.
And, you can see up here it
says that I'm logged in
now with my account.
So, click upload at this
point, very simple example.
I choose a movie file that I
prepared for the purpose.
And, should hopefully happen
very quickly, the file
upload successfully.
For where a much larger file
you'd actually be able to see
on the status message printed
out of every x number of bytes.
I'm not exactly sure
how it's calculate.
But, because we're using the
flash plug-in basically to do
the upload on our behalf, the
flash plug-in exposes nice
events whenever x percent of
the upload has completed.
So, you actually can provide
some feedback to your users
as to how far along the
upload process you are.
So, that was, you know,
what you users might see.
And, it was a very,
very simple example.
It didn't actually ask
for any metadata.
We had some hardcore
metadata in this case.
But, I'm just going to walk you
through some of the relevant
portions of that code
to illustrate the
different processes.
So, this is actually the first
step that we talked about.
This gets triggered after
you select a file.
And it is responsible for
sending the initial metadata
to the browser-based
upload's endpoint.
And, it's going to get back a
response that has a token, and
we'll get to that in a second.
So, I'm just hard coding
some metadata in this case.
Obviously, I could have just as
easily have written something
in you flash file, or you know,
in a HTML form that captured
video title, so and so forth.
Or, you could have used
incomplete metadata.
I'm setting a developer tag,
which we'll talk about
of a little bit.
And, doing a POST
request to the
endpoint.
So, when the post is complete,
this would be fired off.
What I'm doing here is
just really not even
using XML parts.
I'm just using regular
expressions to strip out those
2 elements from the POST
response that I care about,
namely the URL to use as, you
know, the next step where
you upload the file.
And, the unique token to also
include in our request.
So, I'm getting both of those
values, and then I'm calling
the upload file function.
And, what upload file over here
is doing is just adding in what
amounts to -- this is kind of
just faking what a forms
mission would look like.
So, this is, you know, could
be, you could think about it
this is the same sort of data
that would be sent if you
were doing a traditional
browser-based submission.
So, it's adding in
an extra parameter.
And, that contains
the upload token.
And, so using that upload URL
that it previously got from the
first POST response as the
target for the second
file upload stage.
So, this is actually, you know,
create a file reference, and
you could upload on it, and
that actually accomplishes the
upload from the context
of ActionScript.
The complete sample is
available, as, you know, just
Open Source sample code.
The links to it are in
the slide, so definitely
check that out.
If you're doing any sort of
flash development, or if you
just want to see an example
of broswer-based uploads.
So, I'll actually hand
things over to Gareth now.
GARETH McSORLEY: Thanks Jeff.
OK.
So, Jeff has given you some
insight into how you would
perform uploads from a
browser-based application.
And, I'm going to tell you
about the 2 upload mechanisms
we offer for installed
applications primarily.
The first one is what
we call direct upload.
I'm going to be skimming over
this one pretty quickly,
because it's largely been
superseded by the second
mechanism, resumable.
So, this is for
installed applications.
Although, you can also use it
for server side apps, where you
have access to the video file.
The direct uploads while in the
surface may seem to be the
simplest upload mechanism.
It's a single post.
It uses the multi-part related
format, which is one of the
more obscure content types.
And, it's very picky about
how it's formatted.
So, it's quite easy to
incorrectly format these
multi-part related messages,
which is one of the reasons
why resumable is better.
And, again you'll see this time
and time again, don't let users
list uploads into
your own account.
Always let them use one of the
authentication mechanisms.
The temptation for installed
applications is to
use client log in.
But, we really discourage it
in favor of AuthSub or OAuth.
Because, it means that you
don't have to handle the users
credentials, and then there's
no security issues around that.
Obviously, OAuth and AuthSub do
need a browser, but, you know,
let's face it you can
get browser enabled
fridges these days.
So, it shouldn't be too hard
to do a quick redirect to get
an AuthSub or OAuth token.
OK.
So, I'm going to spend a little
more time talking about
resumable uploads.
Especially, since not sp
many of you have done
an upload with the API.
If you're going to get
started, this is probably the
mechanism you should use.
In terms of use case, it's
identical to direct uploads.
You're going to use it
primarily for installed.
Applications.
But, it's a bit more
like the browser upload
that Jeff showed you.
It's a 2 stage process, whereby
you make an initial post.
You're going to get back a
unique URL for your upload.
And, you're going to use that
URL to either provide the
file contents, or query for
the status of the upload.
Wherever client library support
available use resumable.
I think at the moment that
means DotNet and Java, but we
should be rolling out for other
client libraries in the future.
Even where client library
support isn't unavailable,
you may want to consider
using resumable anyway.
As you no doubt noticed from
our keynote yesterday,
even the best networks can
let you down sometimes.
And, whether it's, you know,
uploading your superhighway def
version of Rick Astley, and
having somebody trip over your
network cable, or trying to
upload your latest cute cat
video from your phone, a
failed upload is a really
bad user experience.
And, resumable gives you a way
of avoiding that, and allowing
the upload to continue
under those conditions.
So, it's really perfect for any
mobile devices, or anything
where you may not have a fully
dependable network connection.
And, obviously the bigger
the video, the greater the
payoff in resumable if
something goes wrong.
So, there is a small sample
script just giving you a
rough idea of how to do
resumable uploads on
the Google Code site.
But, what I'm actually going to
do today is kind of walk you
through the protocol, just to
give you a feel for how simple
it actually is to
do this upload.
If any of you are familiar with
Google Gears, and its resumable
HTTP protocol, then this will
be very familiar to you.
So, the opening shot in any
resumable upload is a single
post request to the URL here,
so the this is uploading to a
who doesn't exist,
may not exist.
And, the important points to
know here is the URL starts
with resumable, that's
what indicates it's a
resumable upload rather
than a direct upload.
And, the content type
is nice and simple,
it's not multi-part.
You don't have to format
a complicated body.
It's just the straight OAuth
XML for the video entries.
So, in the body of the request,
you put the XML entry
containing the title and the
description, and so
on and so forth.
The response assuming your
original request is good.
So, we do perform validation
on the original request.
So, if there's something
wrong with the Atom or
if your developer key is
invalid, you'll get an
immediate rejection.
So, you don't have to waste
your time uploading the
file, only to find out
something is wrong.
But, hopefully you've
got an all right, and
you'll get a 200.
And, the important part here
is this location header.
And, the location header
will have this really long
string of the end of it.
A really long URL, which
I truncate it here just
to fit all on a slide.
And, this is your unique
URL for your upload.
So, this is where you're going
to send the file, and also
where you can get information
on the progress of the upload.
So, the next step is
to actually send
the final content.
So, here I'm just going to
try and send an entire
file in one go.
So, I used the URL I got
from the previous step.
And again, we've got nice
simple content type, either
a video type or just
an octet stream.
And.
I just provide the video
file in the body.
So again, no need to format
any multi-part messages.
Assuming everything goes
great, you'll get 2001
created response.
And, that's it.
Your videos is live
and in YouTube.
Now, obviously things
don't work out great.
So, if you get either a time
out on your connection, or if
you get a 500 response of some
sort, you can try and
resume the upload.
And, the way you do that
is by sending a very
particular request.
So, you'll notice it's the same
URL as I was using before --
when I was sending
the file content.
But, this time it's
totally empty.
And, I add this special header,
content range, and the star
slash star means I'm querying
for the status of the upload.
Now, if the upload had
completed successfully, then
what I will get in response
to this, would be
the same created.
So, if it was just the case
that you didn't get the
response, then making the
query would give you back
the completed response.
In the event the upload wasn't
complete, then you'll get this
new response code, the 308.
And, that tells you that
the server has some of the
file but not all of it.
And, the range header's
the interesting part.
It tells you how many bites
the server received thus far.
Then you continue by sending
the file content again.
And, this time we add in a
content range header to tell
the server what part of the
file I'm actually uploading.
You have to continue from
the byte immediately after
the one the server has.
You can't send
overlapping blots.
In my earlier example, I tried
to just upload the whole file
in one go, but you can also use
the content range header
from the very start.
And, upload your
file in chunks.
If it's easier for you for the
file handling, then you can
just upload it in say 10
megabyte chunks by using the
content range header from
the very beginning.
And then, assuming this request
goes through OK, then I'll get
again the 201 a-one created.
If there's another
problem, then I can
try and resume again.
And, basically from the moment
you start a resumable upload,
you've got roughly a
day to complete it.
So, you go plenty of
opportunity to pick up
even in the worst of
network conditions.
So, that's a quick look
into the resumable.
And, now I'm going to give you
a couple of tips and tricks
for handling metadata
for uploaded videos.
So, in the past, we had fairly
strict requirements on this
metadata, you had to provide
us along with the video.
So, you had to give us a
title, you had to give us a
description, and you had to
give us some categories.
There's no way that you can you
can bypass those requirements.
So, you know, for a mobile
device where you may not want
to force the user to enter
these details, or just to make
a nicer upload experience so
the video gets uploaded while
the user is still typing in the
title and description, that he
can get his cute kid video
on the web quicker.
So, you specify this
yt incomplete tag.
And, this tells YouTube that
the metadata on this video is
not going to be complete, and
it should be regarded
as a draft.
What that means is your video
won't show up in searcher until
you've gone into the website,
and updated the metadata, or
updated it through the API.
But, the video itself will
still be uploaded, and
it will be accessible.
So, yeah, this is really ideal
for situations for typing in
the metadata would be
painful for the user.
And, another good reason for
resumable is you even have
the option to send those
absolutely nothing.
So, you can just send totally
empty body, and we'll take it
and treat it as incomplete.
So, to give you example,
this is essentially the
simplest video entry
you can now generate.
And, so you can see that it
just has the basic boilerplate
for an Atom XML entry.
And, then there's just yt and
complete tag, which lives
inside the app control.
And, that's it.
That's all you would
have to provide.
But, you could provide
more if you wanted.
If you wanted to give a title
at this point, you could
certainly do that.
And, certainly this is the
simplest resumable request.
So, you don't provide
anybody at all.
An important point here is
that you don't provide
a content type.
If you specify a content
type, it will fail to parse.
And, on uploads in the past,
we've required a header called
the slug header, and
traditionally this is where you
put the file name of
file you're uploading.
And, the case where you'd give
us incomplete metadata, we're
going to use that header to
generate a standards title,
just as a placeholder.
So, if you are using
this it's worth putting
something meaningful
into the slug header.
Maybe the time stap of when
it was uploaded, or maybe
the device it came from.
OK.
You've heard us mention a few
times now that it's not a good
idea to solicit user uploads
into your own accounts.
And, and not just because we
needed to path out the talk,
it's actually a really
important point.
And, it's like continual source
of problems for partners
who start using the API.
The most common use case
for why people to this, is
they want people to upload
videos using their tool.
And, then they want to be
able to retrieve all
the videos uploaded with
their tool in one go.
Now, there an often overlooked
feature called developer tags,
which gives you exactly the
functionality without the need
to have users uploading
into your account.
A developer tag is a tag
specify an upload time that's
bound to a particular
developer key.
So, the tag is only
visible if you're using
that developer key.
So, on upload you with a media
category as shown there.
And, you just give it
whatever name you like.
The name of your application,
the name of your
favorite pet, whatever.
And, then when you're fetching
the deals from the API, you can
specify the developer tag again
using format shown
at the bottom.
So, this dash followed by the
schema, and then your tag name.
And, as long as you use the
same developer key in both
cases, you'll get back only
the videos that have
your developer tags.
So, only the videos that
were uploaded using
your application.
And, this is a much nicer way
to still have all the videos
accessible without hitting
upload limits, and
things like that.
OK.
So, I'll now hand you back over
to Jeff for some discussion
of mobile uploads.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Thanks
very much Gareth.
So, I'm going to start talking
about mobile uploads by
discussing the Android OS case.
So, let me just say here that
when I'm describing this
initial scenario, I'm talking
about Android phones that I
guess are called Google
Experience phones, and have
the YouTube app built in.
So, in the scenario, what we
recommend and this is a pretty
straightforward approach, is to
use the ACTION_SEND Intents.
Talk to you about intensible
a bit at the keynote
this morning.
But, for those who aren't
familiar with them.
They're basically way of
telling the Android operating
system, that you would like to
do something, optionally
with some piece of data.
So, in this case, we're going
to be using ACTION_SEND Intent,
which as the name kind of
implies, tells the Android
operating system, hey I'd like
to send some data somewhere.
And, the data in this case
is going to be a local
movie file of some sort.
It's not very many lines of
codes that you need to actually
accomplish that sort of thing.
You know, in this particular
case, I'm assuming that there's
a movie file stored in your
SD card called test.move.
You know, this is just
obviously an example.
Probably, what you would be
doing would be capturing video
directly from the video camera
built in on whatever Android
device you are using, saving it
locally, and pointing at that
particular movie files when
calling the ACTION_SEND Intent.
And, I'll go in a little
bit, and show you what
that actually looks like.
But, before I do, I just want
to note that the video will be
uploaded into whatever YouTube
account is associated with the
Android phone, which, you know,
99% of the time is probably
what you want to do.
And, if you do need a little
bit -- I also want to mention
the current ACTION_SEND Intent
isn't so much an API as it is
kind of like a fire and forget
type of thing that doesn't give
you any notifications once the
actual upload is complete.
So, there's not much
information you
can get back it.
And, I've been speaking to the
Google engineers working on the
YouTube app, and they want me
to let you guys know that at
some point in the near future,
we should see some
enhancements here.
And, you will actually be able
to get back some metadata about
the uploaded video once the
ACTION_SEND Intent completes.
That being said, you might want
a little bit more control than
what the ACTION-SEND
Intent offers.
And in that scenario, it's
perfectly fine to just use
either one of the, kind of,
built in HTTP libraries that
Android devices offer.
Or, you could actually use the
newest version of the Google
Data Java client library.
think anything that's in
the 2 O release branch now
works on Android phones.
So, you know, that's another
choice if you don't want to
go through the Intent
based approach.
And, just to show you what
the Intent looks like.
this is basically what the
user would see if you execute
the code on previous page.
And, they'd have a bunch of
different choices as to
how they wanted to share
particular video file.
One of them is going
to be YouTube.
So, select YouTube, the
video will kind of upload
in the background.
And, the user will get notified
when the upload is complete.
But, your code right
now wouldn't.
So, that's the Android
story, also iPhone.
KUAN YONG: Thanks Jeff.
How many of you guys
write iPhone apps?
You can be honest, we know this
a Google event and certain
things were said at a keynote
this morning, but we're trying
to be as inclusive as possible.
So, if you haven't already
dealt with iPhone SKD the next
couple of slides may not make
all that much sense to you.
But, hopefully though at
least show you that it's not
that hard to get started.
The bad news is there is no
equivalent of the ACTION_SEND
Intent on the iPhone.
So, if you want to upload a
video to YouTube in an iPhone
app, you will have to code
against our APIs directly.
And, it's not that hard to do.
So, a typical life cycle of a
video on the iPhone is with the
UI image picker controller.
You create an instance of that,
you present that as a model
view control, and it takes care
of the entire process of
activating the camera
on the phone.
Giving the user a chance to
capture a short snippet of
video, allowing the user to
trim the ends of the video.
And, what you get at the end
of the process is a path to
an mpeg 4 file that's
stores somewhere in the
iPhone file system.
And, what we recommend doing is
once you get that path to the
mpeg 4 file, copy that file to
some place that your app owns.
In most cases, that's
going to be your apps
documents directory.
And, the reason for that is
while you're in a process of
uploading that file, should
your app crash it's not
guarantee that that movie file
is going to be there at that
same place the next time
the user launches your
app.
So, you want to make sure that
you move that file someplace
that ensures they will persist.
Upload a file and wans
you're done uploading,
delete that file.
If you're relatively new to
iPhone programming, one
reminder here is that make
you add the user low memory
situations properly.
The UIImagePickerController
is pretty heavy weight.
So, when you activate it, when
it's on screen, when your
camera is activated, most
likely the phone OS is going to
tell your app to release
all of the views.
Which means when control
returns back to your app, all
of your views are going to had
be reloaded from a nip file, or
recreated programmatically.
And, when that happens, you
just want to make sure that
your views are consistent with
the underline application
state, and it's just an
easy mistake that novice
iPhone programmers make.
Just some sample code.
It's going to be part of the
deck, so I'm not going to
go too much into this.
But, just shows you just basic
code for setting up the
UIImagePickerController.
Setting it up for recording
just videos and not stills.
Presenting that controller.
And displaying the path to your
apps documents directory, so
that you can do a simple copy
of the mpeg 4 file from the
temporary location to
your app's location.
A few additional
tips and tricks.
So, we do have an objectives
c-client library.
But, it's pretty heavyweight.
So, if you want to use
that, you know, we
don't really blame you.
If you want to handroll your
own HTTP requests, one open
source objectives CHTTPRequest
library I like using
is ASIHTTPRequest.
And, you can check it out
at the link over there.
It makes it really easy to do
things like display a progress
bar, you know, while the
post is in progress.
If you are going to be
hand rolling you own HTTP
API, you're probably not
want to deal with XML.
You will want to check out
our new compact JSON output
format, which we call JSON-C.
And, there's tons, you know,
open source iPhon libraries
for parsing JSON.
So, I highly recommend that you
guys go down that approach.
So, to see all this code in
action, we have some sample
code that's part of our YouTube
Direct open source project.
If you go to the link, there
is a sample iPhone app
that you can take a look.
It currently uses the older,
you know, single post
direct upload method.
But, it should be very easy to
convert that to one that uses
the resumable upload API,
again as I just talked about.
And, one last tip.
If you haven't already figured
out how to play a YouTube video
within an iPhone app, there's
really a simple way to do so.
All you have to do is create a
UI web view within your app.
And, just give it some HTML
that is just the usual
YouTube, and then snip it.
And, what it does is enables
the Safari plug-in to convert
the flash embed, and do
something that the user can
actually interact with.
And, on the iPad, the
experience is really nice,
because the video will play
in line within your app.
So, the user doesn't have to
leave your app to a different
screen to watch a video
and come back to it.
The video will play as
part of your apps UI.
And, the overall user
experience is really nice.
I recommed you guys
check it out.
Alright.
So, back to Jeff to talk
about YouTube Direct.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Thanks Kuan.
So, YouTube Direct.
Some of you might be familiar
with it, but probably most not.
So, let me just give you a
review of exactly what it is.
YouTube Direct is basically it
comes down to is an App Engine
instance running some open
source code that's built on
top of the YouTube APIs.
Running it is as a complete
open source project.
Kind of the model that we see
people doing is downloading the
code, creating their App Engine
instance, and deploying it.
The reason why people might
want to use YouTube Direct
makes it, we hope, easier to
embed a upload interface on
any arbitrary website, and
solicit YouTube videos.
So, it's using browser-based
uploads under the hood that
we are already discussed.
And, one of the, you know,
initial types of partners that
we've reached out to have
been news organizations.
And, we've been trying to
promote citizen journalism,
and things along those lines.
And, that's absolutely great.
But, we want to make sure that
people knew that, you know,
that's not the only potential
uses for YouTube direct.
Pretty much any website where
you think it would be nice to
have a way of soliciting
contents in response to, you
know, certain calls to action
that might have on your page,
or just general, you know,
upload your video responses
to so and so forth.
You can do that using YouTube
Direct pretty easily.
So, there's two different
components of YouTube Direct,
one of which is kind of the
use and user facing iFrame.
And, this is what kind of
hosts the whole browser
base upload interface.
There's also a back end, admin
only moderation panel, that
lets you keep track of all the
videos that have
been submitted.
And, moderates those videos.
And, moderation refers to the
ability to add videos that you
do choose to, you know, accept
into a playlist that will
live in your own account.
Or, additionally, update the
metadata of those videos to
potentially contain
a link back to
your websites.
Some way branding the fact that
those videos were uploaded, you
know, by your YouTube
Direct instance.
So, that's all part of
the open source project.
So, we have a demo.
This is a little
abstract to talk about.
I just have App Engine
instance set up for
this purpose over here.
You know, this happens to be
running on App Engine itself,
YTD [? demo.appspot ?]
com.
But, this actual page does not
have to be on App Engine.
This, you know, think of that
as, you know, something that
can potentially be on
your own website.
It's just this content over
here, and what happened was
that an iFrame was dynamically
inserted into the page.
This is what is running,
this is what has to
run on App Engine.
So, in this case click
on login into YouTube.
Maybe remember from a little
bit earlier, where I was doing
the flash based example.
It's more or less doing
the same sort of AuthSub
authorization step.
In this case, I was registered
ahead of time with this
particular demand.
So, you get nicer message
saying registered, secure.
And, hopefully users at that
point will click allow access.
And, you get redirected back
to the page that you are on.
Those are logged in to my
account at this point.
And, there are two
different options.
You can either submit
an existing video.
And, I'll show you
that briefly.
It uses a YouTube API to load
in the most recent videos that
were uploaded in your account.
That's not really what I want
to demo though, I'd like to
show you just the upload
a new video flow.
Because, this is what's
actually using the
browser-based uploads rather
than just calling a video
that's already live
in the account.
We're obviously not doing a YTM
complete here, we're actually
collecting some metadata.
The rest of the form is kind of
optional, and because this is
an open source project, you
have full access to the coe.
You could adjust the types
of information that
you'd like to collect.
You know, certainly for this
purpose I'm not going to put
in my phone number or
anything like that.
AppEngine does have the
ability to send out emails.
So, if I wanted I could fill
in email address here.
I would get notified when the
moderator of this YouTube
Direct instance decides to,
you know, either accept
or reject the video.
But, in this case I'm just
going to choose the file,
I'm going to choose the
same file from before.
And, click upload.
So, what's was worth noting is
that as I'm uploading this
video, it's going live
into my own account.
My Jeff [? passing ?]
test account.
S, regardless of whether
anybody moderates a video and
approves it or not, this
video is live on YouTube.
Moderation step only effects
whether the master account for
the YouTube Direct instance
will include that video in a
playlist, or include some text
linking back to this
particular package.
So, I will show you the
admin interface, briefly.
I'm running a little
bit low on time.
So, I won't spend too
much time on that.
is basically something I threw
together with all the different
uploads and a list over here.
I'll click on details, it pulls
in the video details from a
combination of some stored
locally in the data store, from
App Engine, but it also will
sink anything that's been
updated using the YouTube
API, and pull that down.
It'll let you
preview the video.
Let's you actually, a new
feature that we added
was the ability to edit
captions for the video.
So, we're kind of seeing some
potentially cool uses for that
with some organizations that
want to allow people to upload
videos, and then they'll do
captions, and update the
captions are live on
the YouTube instance.
So, that's a pretty cool use.
And, at this point, you know,
kind of choose, whether
approve or reject the
video, so and so forth.
So I just wanted to go
back to the slides.
We went through all of this.
And, you know, just brief kind
of high picture overview of how
we've build YouTube Direct.
At the center, you know, an
inappropriate is App Engine.
So, this is a written
using actually the Java
version of App Engine.
Bunch of JSPs and servlets.
We're making use of App
Engine data store.
We're keeping track of a whole
bunch of things, including the
off sub token session
information, video metadata,
things like that.
We talked to the YouTube API
obviously to sync metadata
and do the actual
browser-based uploads.
We're talking to Google
Accounts for getting the
YouTube credentials
for the given user.
And, we're talking to the host
website, so the host website,
you know, loads in some
JavaScripts, you know, when you
click on whatever button
triggers the upload process it
basically dynamically inserts
the iFrame into the site.
And, there's the ability, you
know, in the admin panel, which
we didn't spend too much time
talking about to have configure
different options for your
YouTube API settings, and
to moderate videos
as they come in.
So, that's pretty much
what I wanted to cover
about YouTube Direct.
We're going to take some
questions at this point.
And, I'm going to pull up the
link for the Google Wave again
that has moderator instance.
Definitely in addition to the
questions that come from
moderator, feel free
to come up to
the mic, and ask any
questions locally too.
So, if you guys want to
come up to while they
handle the questions.
Take the first from
the audience.
AUDIENCE: You guys keep on
talking about, you know, you
really want to have the
users themselves upload the
videos to your [INAUDIBLE]
account.
Which I understand.
It makes sense.
However, as far as a user
experience, you have a lot
of old people who don't
have YouTube accounts.
When I took videos from them,
it just doesn't seem to make
sense as far as, you know, to
get videos from a wide
range of audience.
And, so we're trying to figure
out is, you know, for our
organization, we're trying to
figure out how exactly to
make that work properly.
And, especially since doing --
I've used YouTube Direct a
little bit, and doing the
iFrame and all that
is kind of clunky.
It's just, you know, you
have to go back and forth
between the websites.
It just makes it a very
difficult process.
And, we're try to figure
out, you know, what's the
best way of doing that.
Is it better to use
direct login through our
website, or, you know.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'll
take some of that.
And other people can jump in.
So, I guess first of all, you
know, we might have slightly
different opinions in that
we think people creating
YouTube accounts and having
YouTube is pretty great.
Obviously, you know, it might
be an extra step for a user to
have to authorize
the application.
It is a one-time step.
Once you do the AuthSub login,
you can reuse that token, and
you'll have access to that
account pretty much
indefinitely.
In case you think that your
users are going to be
interacting with your website,
you know, in a daily basis.
That gets around
things a little bit.
I mean that being said, yeah,
you know, it is easier to do
the approach where you
upload all your videos
into one account.
And, we do see a lot of people
who end up doing that.
As somebody who has to deal
with the aftermath of people
who decide that they're going
to live with that sort of
approach, and don't realize
what our limitations are, I can
tell you that it's just really
not how we have things set up.
I mean, I don't want to any
potential legal issues or
anything like that, but it's
also problematic from
that point of view.
Beyond, whatever, you know,
restriction we have on the
size videos and accounts.
So, I don't have an answer for
you in terms of saying, you
know, this is a magical other
approach you can take.
It's a sort of thing where
you really do need to.
And, I think users across the
web need to get used to having
this sort of interstitial page
where you login on a trusted
site, and you grant
access to other things.
And, I think across the
Google APIs, you'll
see that same model.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yep.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
Take another from the audience.
AUDIENCE: A lot of people are
using YouTube for search
engine optimization in
trying to drive traffic.
And, they're labeling videos
with things that don't relate
to what the video's about.
And, I'm wondering if you're
planning on using voice
recognition, so that you have
an idea of what the video is
about, other than just what
people are calling it.
KUAN YONG: Did you
mean the tags?
AUDIENCE: The tags.
Yes.
The tags don't always match
with video is about.
But, Google has this great
voice recognition thing.
KUAN YONG: Right.
We haven't really spoken a
lot about this publicly.
But, we do have automated
classification systems
that are going on.
Like, for example, when you go
to YouTube.com and you start
browsing videos by categories,
we don't just go by the
categories that a
user tells us.
We actually classify some of
the videos through other means.
So, we have some of
this information.
I'll take what you've
just said back to the
team.
It's something we could
potentially look at.
Maybe exposing some of the tags
that came out of the automatic
video classification process.
Right now these are not
exposed, but we could
potentially expose
them in the future.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'm just going
to switch to the moderator real
quick, and make sure we get a
couple questions from there.
Will there be an HTML5 version
of the Chromos player
at some point.
I assume also the Chromos
player refers to both the
player that doesn't have all
the Chrome, and also the
standard embedded player that
you see pretty much
across the web.
I made sure to talk to the
Players Team before I came,
because I had a feeling it will
be a question about this.
The answer is yes.
There will be a way of
embedding HTML5 player
video into your webpages.
Much like you do right
now with Flash Player.
It's not something that we're
really ready to commit to a
specific implementation
right now.
It's really just not very
far along in deciding
how it's going to done.
It probably will be an
iFrame of some sort.
And, a JavaScript object
that ends up being
loaded in an exposed.
The same sort of API
we have right now.
I think, you know, hopefully
we'll match the existing API.
So, you shouldn't have to
rewrite too much of your
custom, you know, player
control logic and
things like that.
But, under but under the hood
it's going to be completely
different obviously.
So, stay tuned pretty much.
We should have something.
Take another from the audience.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sorry,
I have a lot of questions
here I'll try to be brief.
First, where our institution
is trying to use this almost
as a workflow system.
We have some people from our
Media Department who were
sending stuff up to PR.
And, it is uploaded to an
institutional account, and
they're trying to send it up to
another department on the
University to approve it before
it goes live on the web.
So, that might be an
interesting use case study for
having functional accounts,
multiple counts, not
only a user accunt.
Secondly, for the gentleman
that was before me.
Are you guys using any of the
automated generated captions
to end search data?
And, can you speak
to the captions?
KUAN YONG: Yes.
We do use autogenerated
captions as part of the
search ranking secret
sauce, blah, blah blah.
We currently don't have a way
to expose those automatically
generated captions to
the API right now.
The reasons for that are
mostly legal in nature.
So, I can't really go too
much into this stuff.
So, I hope that answers your
question about captions.
AUDIENCE: Sort of.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
I'll try to get through as
many other ones as we can.
I have a video hosted
at my own server.
Is there a way to get the
video from a given URL rather
than from a local file.
I guess that's during
the upload stage.
No.
That's not something
you can do.
I guess so it basically have
our servers fetch the video
file from a well defined URL
instead of including
it in the request.
But, no.
I don't know if that's
something we're even thinking
about doing it necessarily.
GARETH McSORLEY: Yeah.
Not something I've heard about
anyone thinking of dong.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
Sorry about that.
And, let see.
We use the API to
autogenerate captions.
Such a copy of those generated
captions cleanup locally using
heuristics and upload to
clean captions file.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Kuan?
KUAN YONG: We kind
of answered that.
So, the autogenerated captions
are not available through
the API unfortunately.
JEFFREY POSNICK: But,
you can upload you own
captions using the API.
KUAN YONG: If you're the
owner of that video.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Let's see.
Can you add metatags for SCO?
So, I guess this will be
additional tags that were
just visible by search
engines perhaps.
KUAN YONG: I don't think so.
Because, you're talking about a
standard YouTube watch page,
and that's not something that
third parties have
control over.
JEFFREY POSNICK: With resumable
uploads when we slice large
files into small pieces, is it
possible to upload the pieces
out of order simultaneously?
GARETH McSORLEY: Yeah.
The simple answer is
unfortunately not yet.
So, at the moment the rules
for resumable uploads
are very strict.
You have to upload all
the bytes in sequence.
And, you can't upload
any overlapping chunks.
But, stay tuned, we're hoping
to relax those requirements
in the near future.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Right.
And, ending on a high note.
Will there ever be a way to
download YouTube videos that
does not violate the
terms of service?
KUAN YONG: Well, the
answer is simple.
No.
Not so because we're terrible
people, but the license
agreement that we have with
anybody who uploads a video to
YouTube, you know, whether it's
your mom or some huge studio is
that we'll use your videos only
for streaming purposes.
So, any use cases that does not
involve streaming, cannot be
supported through the API.
So, no downloads.
AUDIENCE: Now I
have a question.
If I want to upload the video,
I'd like to make, I have new
version of the temp video.
But, I would like to keep
all of the data of the old.
Because, it's new
version, not new video.
Is there any way to keep that.
For example, I do all the
advertising for a particular
video, and now when they're
making a new version you need
to replace all the odds,
and it takes a lot of
time to improve them.
KUAN YONG: Yeah.
There's no way for us to
support that if you're
just a regular user
uploading to YouTube.
We do have some super high
tier content partners
that require the ability
to swap out a video.
But, we can't offer this
generally, because then you
have a whole bunch of beat and
switch videos where somebody
gets a video really popular,
and just kind of keeps
swapping, you know, videos
into that same video ID.
So, something like that
is going to be a dooz
really, really easily.
So, that's just the
reality of the situation.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
I have a feeling we're
pretty much out of time.
Thank you everybody.
KUAN YONG: Thanks
for being Here.